sesame street is once again normalizing
all different types of people to the new
generation for the first time they just
introduced a family with two dads
we're here
okay everybody everybody i want you to
meet my brother dave
hi his husband frank hello and my
sabrina mia
my niece hi mia daddy
sesame street is even more amazing than
he said
we're glad you like it you're almost so
happy that you're out here
are you kidding we wouldn't have missed
family day for anything
oh we better get this food ready the
party's about to start that's wrong good
idea tiannina yeah lead the way
okay
and now nelson says finally that's funny
i was thinking like people for years
have you know ran into the burt and
ernie
friendship the roommate situation like
yeah that is like it's a gay
relationship so now it's nice that
we don't look to allegories or whatever
maybe maybe
like there's a full out here's two dads
with a kid living their lives
yeah this is another one of those and i
don't want to take away from the moment
like i love it
but this is another one of those like oh
i didn't realize that
it was 2021 that they did this i i look
in my head i think of sesame street and
i i could have imagined
easily that this is something that was
introduced years ago but here we are in
2012
excuse me 2021 when we're doing it which
is great but again i thought
oh okay i was a little bit surprised
that it's something that was that was so
recent
i do love the way that it's done though
um
and that it is an introduction and it is
and that's what it is here's this person
here's this person here's this person
okay we're gonna go hang out and have a
good time now
um yeah so yeah like when you said in
the introduction this is normalizing
what this is because yeah it's a
it's a normal thing and it is a
beautiful thing um
i know from experience of like hanging
out with my
two kids that you really do shape
their view of everything around them so
the idea that they would not think it's
cool like hypothetically if there's a
kid out there that doesn't think it's
cool that there are two dads
it's because someone said to them that
it's not cool or didn't show them that
it could be a cool normal thing
and so this is an important step that i
think you know
children's programming in general could
be doing
and should be doing to just show how um
the diversity of life of couples of
families
and uh and just show kids that like it's
all cool let's all just get along
yeah and everyone's kind of saying what
you just said samantha says yeah it's
kind of late
and says it's so cute i wish they had
started it earlier
um people says have had a two mom family
uh pizzas still love um uh
sesame street it's taking this long to
have a two dad family yeah it is a
little bit strange because usually with
these things
sesame street is so progressive like
usually at the beginning of the curve or
at least like
on the up curve of these kind of things
so yeah this does seem a little bit late
but hey i'm not going to fault him for
finally doing it and yeah like you said
it's just presented it's just
hey here's frank and i can't remember
those guys saying okay we're gonna go do
this like there's no
kind of yeah question like oh there's
two dads it's just normalized like i
know that was a big thing that dan levy
talked about was shit's creek
through that whole show other than his
pe his uh patrick's parents were a
little bit hesitant to
except he was gay but in terms of in the
town of shits creek not once did anyone
in that town be like
you know question that relationship or
have a problem with um
with david and patrick's relationships
yeah this thing just showed normal life
and that and that's the thing i mean
like you said i would love to see a
video of a
two to seven year old watching that
episode and saying
two dads and throwing down their toys
and getting mad and
no it's the parents no certain parents
that are
that are going to get upset about this
and teach it to their kids that that's
not right and blah blah so it's like
this yeah the younger generation just
doesn't
care it's just yeah it's all normal so
it's great the sesame street just
presenting it that way too it's just
it's nothing not a big deal
you know having having worked in uh
children's tv for
a very very long time before i joined
you guys um
you know i have a strong opinion about
the idea of how we represent people
families people of different cultures to
young people to kids
because if it's not if you don't
immediately see it in your household
like if you're in a household that
doesn't have that um
diversity or or those different
perspectives
you're going to get it from either
friends school teachers or media
and the most immediate one especially in
a time like ours when you're
just at home and kids are just watching
netflix or youtube or tv or whatever
is through media so the more that you
show them
from a young age when they're still
learning the ways of the world so to
speak
that all this stuff is cool and
everybody can be cool because everything
is normal and like let's celebrate
everyone
then that's how they're gonna grow up
they're gonna go up and go oh yeah of
course that's that's normal
why would that why would i why would i
ever hate people for being two dads why
would i ever do that
like just just show it as a normal thing
to them growing up
and that's like a big step towards
this generation like the young
generation now being
way ahead of what our generation was as
we were growing up
yeah absolutely yeah it's not that hard
people so good job sesame street